what a nice season he's having he leads the
ducks with 14 goals and 23 points is number
77 who does nothing but shoot the pop if it's
a two-on-one number 77 who has it now will be
shooting it it's all about volume for him
well on Pace to pass his career high of 24
goals while with Florida knocked out of the
air by Henrik Henrik brings it in amazingly
enough last night against his former team
the Devils his first career hattrick gutus
with a shot he scores wow wow rco gutus
with his fifth goal of the Season makes
it one to nothing what screened or not
I suspect that he may have been goodus
with a good R shot but you're not supposed to
score unless that hits something and change
direction right up under the crossbar for sure and
at that angle Troy Terry on it it number 19 in for
Leo Carlson the rookie number 91 the 18-year-old
who turned 19 just after Christmas back to gas a
shot oh H stopped at rebound oh and set wide whoo
couldn't control the rebound and the Ducks Terry
couldn't bury it we a couple of close calls for
the Anaheim Ducks here that went off Petrie's foot
and then a juicy rebound to nobody's fault how
do you oh there's how Miss got stick on it with
34 points same as Detroit and it goes for color
sent in on husso Puck loose held in scores another
point shot from nearly the same place this one
from the rookie defenseman pavl mikov getting his
second goal the former sagonos Spirit star back of
the net and it looks like it might have deflected
it did deflect off Dyan Lin his right leg it look
like and right into the top corner there's a good
angle look at it there's that deflection right
there it is a game of 16th and eighth of an inch
and that's a good example of it right there into
the slot and comes back to the line for gos spare
again and they cck hatch to bring it in gos to
spare and one more time slot shot save Puck loose
picked up by Anaheim and clear now I suppose if
he wanted to get some shots in the intermission
he could go to the practice rank right they do
have one here could go over to bort there's a
shot scores squeaks through his legs deflected in
front deflection in front of the net a power play
goal Adam Henrik I think for Devil's team Adam
Henrik Cam Fowler with his head up all the way I
mean he's looking this is a shot pass right there
redirection a goalie can only hope it hits him on
on a play like this he did get a piece of it but
uh perfect execution by Anna felt it there by
HOV around by Rymer picked off by Terry who
got hit held in save Rymer rebound they score
Troy Terry off a rebound given up by Rhymer
off a soft shot from the Blue Line well and
the ducks have four on the board this
started when Mor cider had trouble back
in behind for cop off the errant stick from
sherat who goes to the bench shot oh it's
underway Turner was distracted try to
figure out why it doesn't hit anything
will a challenge for go tender interference I
don't think so although fabry was big reason
why they needed to Brink it a big reason
why they needed Kane here it is for Petri
Petri circling oh nearly buried that
on the wrap around for another two goal
game well you get help the goer
gets help from his defenseman
on that one and Petri just could
not wrap around far enough to tuck
in as the Ducks bring it in LOL with a pass
across and knocked away in a recovery by
Lon and a shot goes high right over the
net and Rhymer to make the save Patrick
Kane gos is beir to Kane tried for
to Brink it it was blocked back to
the point off the cross that had a
funny sound that had a funny sound
he takes no prisoners matter what color
jersey he's got on he did it with Tampa
Bay now Anaheim with pixie dust all over them on
a couple of these chances tonight
that last one off the bottom of the
bar kept in here by Fowler Thorn to Carlson
back for Fowler Carlson tipped in front two
good stops a spin play then gets knocked
off the park by sherat to Brink it look
at Kane on the far side Kane's got it shot
behind Kane firing and a save by Dostal Kane
coming close he's got an assist tonight can't
beat doal we'll be back looks to Kane do is
for kanane across scars to break
it the birthday boy makes it 4 to
two they obviously wanted the pluck on the stick
of number 88 gois bear goes there right now and
through the seam Patrick Kane like nobody else
can do I mean absolutely perfect and a finish
by to Brink it for the power play goal his 400th
career point stop that and fowers got it kicked
that and missed that by sherat that allowed the
Ducks to come in with a chance and a save made
off M got it now and turns back and holds in
he presented his stick to make that play back
for sherat 10 to go in the four on four right
out front the Bret's got itong left it there
Raymond carries for Ras mus to Raymond tried to
go back to the line it was blocked Raymond good
second effort to keep control now for spraw
fights off a check penalty over there's a
shot and a piece of that fight I stallen wide
Kane on the wing Lin checked by vetrano gosis
bear Patrick Kane TI to to Brink it gsus
bear save by doall starts since and hasn't
won heading into the game tonight one of
those games was a one- nothing loss to
Chicago he came on in relief of John Gibson last
night with no decision Bobble Kane's got it again
took the shot save made rebound cleared by
lbushkin watch up blue ra tired Ducks lens
got it back to gses Bear two and a half to
go in the third scar D breakout it's for a
free at what point did the puck go in is the
second penalty over and that's what they're
discussing now that's the question Mark where 159
showing on the clock which means both penalties
would come out as the Anaheim Ducks backto
back wins backto back nights 51 last night
in New Jersey and they win tonight 4 to3 over
Detroit to go home for an eight-game home stand